well dave portnoy first became famous
for barstool sports but then he became a
cultural phenomenon the last year he's
raised more than 40 million dollars for
small businesses suffering under corona
he also has a massive social media
following because he is a free thinker
he's not explicitly political or really
political at all but he says what he
thinks and that's a rare thing and the
authorities don't like it
yesterday he announced that he suspects
he's being shadow banned on social media
platforms that means these platforms are
making it hard or impossible for people
to view his posts here's what he said
emergency press conference i'm getting
shadow banned i mean come on instagram i
had 100 followers last night give me a
break that's a joke tick tock i can't
buy a comment six comments on a video i
comment where the comments no comments
nothing is working nothing is showing up
is it big pizza is big pizza after me
big frozen pizza because digerno did a
recall not my fault is it big finance
because i still keep digging into the
amc thing new trades i don't know what
could it be
what could it be that's the question we
thought we would ask dave portnoy
directly he joins us tonight dave thanks
a lot for coming on so first of all good
for you for calling them on this in
public that's that's really our only
defense is sunlight here
why do you think
they would do this to you you're not
running for anything are you
no i'm not running for anything you
never really know why they're doing it
varies every time you know there is
something to say it's the algorithm and
it may not be as devious but the
algorithm certainly plays to people
maybe more on the liberal side who don't
like things you have to say so could it
be i made fun of aoc for that tax dress
when she's celebrating the rich that
could be it that actually got you know a
little warning that this may be fake
news and all i said was she was at the
richest party the rich that's really not
like anything you have to check that's
like saying it's getting dark tonight
people may not like that big pizza i'm
joking digiorno nestle who knows uh
finance i certainly have gone hard at
the amc in the billionaires club so
there's so many different angles but one
thing's for sure if
people in a certain side and it tends to
be the big social media platforms don't
like what you have to say there's no
doubt that you start disappearing and
whether you like trump don't like trump
i'm i have no opinion on it the fact
they kicked him off you know twitter and
social media totally and then you have
like at one point the taliban on there
there's no rhyme or reason for what's
happening basically in social media and
it's important because so many people
get their information from that it
really should be freedom of the press
but you can't suppress people at least
you shouldn't be able to well shadow
banning is the stealthiest way the most
passive aggressive feline creepy way to
do it if they want you off twitter just
say hey dave porno you can't use twitter
anymore or instagram or whatever the
platform is but to shadow ban you you
don't even know what's happening
yeah well then you become the if you
don't like me you become the crazy guy
with strings in your in your apartment
be like oh this guy did it if they came
out and said hey we're banning dave
because he said something that the tax
the rich or big pizza or a big finance
there'd be an uproar here it's kind of
hard to prove outside the very specific
facts that you know one day or two days
in a row i get no new followers on
instagram you kind of have to be savvy
in that language that's impossible that
just can't happen when you have as many
followers as i do i'll go six months
with thousands every day and then
suddenly i have two i said something
that people didn't like
i joked at the outset you're not running
for anything but what if you wanted to
run for something you can't really run
for office in this country without
social media that's how you get your
message out so i mean these companies
are basically controlling our elections
i mean how are they not
yeah well
yeah i mean that you certainly can put
what is in people's feeds and i get that
a lot with my own it's like listen dave
we look at every single thing you do
whether it's pizza or whatever and we
can't find you like it takes 10 minutes
to find your post that's obviously a
problem and if they're banning me by the
way i eat pizza like that my instagram
goes down it's 99 taking bites of pizzas
like if they're gonna ban me for that or
suppress me god knows what they're doing
to really political people that's right
um so it is a little bit nuts it is a
little bit nuts you humiliated and tamed
the nfl commissioner roger goodell i
hope you do the same thing to google and
facebook i really do we're we're rooting
for you dave portnoy thank you
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else